hello everyone welcome to today's live
web broadcast advances in perioperative
care promoting good animal welfare and
good science i'm brenda kelly kim of lab
roots and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kent scientific
kent scientific is the world leader in
non-invasive blood pressure measuring
equipment for mice and rats for more
information please visit
www.kentscientific.com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the q
a box which can be found by clicking on
the green q a button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or ultimately submit your
question through the green q a button
lower left
i would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr paul flecknow dr flecknell is
currently director of the comparative
biology center at the university of
newcastle and is the professor of
laboratory animal science at the
institute of neuroscience his main
research interests are anesthesia and
analgesia of all species of animals and
in particular the development of methods
of pain assessment i will now turn it
over to dr fleck now for his
presentation
thank you for that in introduction um
hello everybody um it's really great to
be participating in this event and i
suppose i should say good morning good
afternoon and good evening depending on
where you're logging in from
the
session
today is going to be split roughly in
half
in the first section i'm going to talk
primarily about advances in
intraoperative care and how we might
apply them
including a brief discussion of some of
the newer anesthetics we have available
and in the second half talk about some
of the really interesting developments
in pain assessment that are almost ready
for cage side use in our facilities
so
the reason for wanting to talk about
this is that these advances that we're
getting in the whole of the
perioperative area will allow us not
just to improve the quality of
scientific data
but naturally lead to improvements in
animal welfare
so first of all let's talk about new
anaesthetics although actually they're
not so new um most of the agents uh that
i'm going to mention have been around
for quite a while in one formulation or
another
but what we're seeing is
a change in availability between
different countries and continents a
change in formulation and a slow move i
think by the lab animal science
community
to
take on board some of these newer agents
rather than sticking with with more
traditional methods
so i'm going to talk about silver
fluorine and isofluorine
about alpha axel alphaxane and propofol
and dex-meditomidine and meditomodine
and xylazine
i was fortunate enough to have a holiday
in florida
ending up with doing some work at the
north american veterinary conference and
so i was able to see that al faksan has
just been launched in north america um
so we can talk about that and not be
talking about something that you would
have to import
first of all though let's just look at
what's being used at present uh in
lab animal units and this was a
literature survey that was brought up to
date by robert dorwan who is a vet
student at nottingham who spent some
time with us doing a literature review
robert looked at the reported
anaesthetic use in papers that involved
surgical procedures in rats and mice
and
as you can see over the two time periods
uh between 2005 6 and 2012 13
there's some changes uh there are
changes that we might expect like
pentabarbital
has dropped in popularity
because of course it's uh no longer
easily available as an anaesthetic
preparation
but we still see
extensive use of ketamine xylazine older
agents like chlorohydrate and
tribromoethanol
i should add all of which have their
place in certain
research settings
but we're dominated by
ketamine cocktails
plus barbiturates and no sign of some of
these newer agents
i don't think dexmed automodeen was
mentioned once i think we had one paper
or with ketamine metatamidine i should
add that i'm not ignoring the inhalants
but the injectable anaesthetics make
made up over 70 percent of all
anesthetics given to small rodents
so why so conservative because we we do
have other agents available and this was
my
quick uh and
very brief survey using a simple google
scholar
citation search
looking at the individual anaesthetics
all the ones that i could come up with
and i did include their
alternative name so averting went in as
a vertian anders tribromoethanol
and i looked for any of these agents
together with rat or mouse or rats or
mice
and then expressed this as a percent of
the citations
and you can see that
early on
we had ether dominating but then as
anaesthetic ether
became unavailable
and as we realized the disadvantages of
this agent it slipped from use
we had pentebarbital
used consistently throughout the 70s 80s
90s and the 2000s
that we're going to see subside again
because of
a lack of availability in many countries
of anaesthetic formulation
and
we see the rise of
ketamine steadily
and to a lesser extent
um early on but gaining ground
isofluorine
what we don't see is a great deal of use
of uh desperatine or siva fluorine um or
propofol or alfaxone
all the lines that hover around along
the bottom around the naught to five
percent mark tend to be papers that
for the newer agents that are actually
describing the interaction of that agent
with particular body systems with an
interest for example in neuro protective
effects of some agents and so forth so i
think it's fair to say based on both
those analyses
that we're a fairly conservative
group
and of course there are good reasons for
that
the uh
newer agents although we have good data
on them we have less track record using
them in a research animal setting
and
many research workers will say if you
say how about switching to silver
fluorine and giving it a try compared to
isofluorine i've used isofluorine for 10
years it works well
i don't really want to change so why
might you well certainly
from our experiences of mass induction
of many species and indeed the
literature reports of mass induction of
children and adults with sibo fluorine
as compared to isofloraine
we see
okay
i'm just checking on a question
um before we leave those injectables
someone was asking about why is there a
resurgence in the use of plural hydrate
and i think probably
with a sample of only 100 publications
it is susceptible to a few papers
popping up from particular journals and
chlorohydrates still very popular with
neuropharmacological studies
because of its
rather unique mode of action of not
interacting with
many specific uh
neurotransmitters in
as great a way as perhaps ketamine does
for example with nmda receptors
so i think chlorohydrate and indeed
chloroloes are going to be withers
for so long as
particular groups of research workers
see a specific advantage to the
pharmacology of that anaesthetic
so back to um
see the fluorine it's less pungent it's
better tolerated uh the induction times
are faster quite markedly so
the recovery times also ought to be
faster but in our experience what tends
to happen is animals pass into a state
of sleep if you don't disturb them
and then when they do recover the
recovery is very much smoother than with
isoflurane or indeed with halothane
isofluorine of course has the advantage
that it undergoes virtually no
biotransformation and it's all exhaled
sibo fluorine does have a little uh
proportion of the drug metabolized
rather than exhaled but not
to any significant extent but once again
it's a factor you'd take into
account
it is still significantly more expensive
even though i believe it's
now available as a generic or certainly
from several manufacturers rather than
the original patent holder
the other drawback is that you need
an agent-specific calibrated vaporizer
it's a highly potent anaesthetic so you
can't simply drop it on cotton wool and
put it into a an anaesthetic chamber at
least you can't if you want to use it
safely
you need a vaporizer like this one for
example which is for silver fluorine if
you put it in a a halothane or a nicer
flooring vaporizer you certainly won't
get
what it says on the dial
the alternative is to buy a multi-agent
system
like this one
not only does this have the advantage of
allowing you to put either isofluorine
or silver fluorine in the syringe which
is used to deliver the anaesthetic
but it's designed for low flows for
rodents so this device is a syringe
driver
that injects
uh anesthetic
down into a heated block where the
vapor's mixed with
anesthetic gases and then delivered
to the animal
and with that system you can use um both
isoflurane and
silver fluorine
someone's asked if i'll make the slides
available uh yes i believe
that's
that will be that will be happening
so it costs more um but then let's just
take a step back and think why does it
cost more for those of you working with
large species yes it will cost more
but moving to
close circuit anesthesia with fresh gas
flows of one to two hundred mils a
minute and a
circuit breathing system and you can
reduce those costs significantly
for those of you working with rodents i
will lay odds that many of you who work
with
mouse particularly
will be using fresh gas flows from your
anaesthetic machine of one liter a
minute or greater
and one of the reasons that you'll be
doing that
is that you've been told because of
health and safety you should be quite
correctly be removing waste anaesthetic
gases
and you may be using a system like this
one
and this has an inner
mass that delivers the anaesthetic and
an outer one that removes the waste
anaesthetic gas so you don't breathe it
only the mouse does
it's great it works well
but if you drop the flows down as some
of you may have experienced
the
gas is entrained from the inner mask and
the animals will wake up which is
not something you want to happen
if however you use a low flow system and
then you can use much more appropriate
flows i've been extremely generous in
the calculations here i was redoing them
while sitting waiting and actually
minute volumes of mice is uh less than
15 mils for the average mouse
you take
um the volume of one breath multiply it
by the respiratory rate and you get the
minute volume to stop the animal
breathing back in the gases breathed out
and inhaling carbon dioxide
when it's on a face mask you need about
three times that volume
so we could use uh fresh gas flows of
actually as little as about 30 mls never
mind 45 mils with a 30 gram mouse
and the calculation for the rat depends
on the size of your rat
but for mouse the potential fresh gas
savings are enormous and of course it's
not just the gas it's the anaesthetic
vapor that it contains
so low flow systems um this system
is all uh appropriate low flows uh with
a small low dead space mask you can also
buy
passive scavenged masks from a variety
of vendors
where the flows are so low and the seal
around the mask
is good around the mask around the
mouse's nose so the gas disappears away
from you
but i
i will also almost guarantee that if
you're working with mice
and you use flows of less than 50 ml a
minute
you will find that uh the natural
ventilate room ventilation and the fact
that the gases are heavier than air will
keep them well away from you
uh if you're doing surgery on the mouse
the only caveat i should add to that
is that some of the vaporizers that you
may have
may not perform accurately at these very
low flows and indeed the flow meter on
your anaesthetic machine may only go
down to 100 mils
so you may need to invest in in a flow
meter
and a vaporizer that will run at those
flows in order to make these savings
however it's worth thinking about if
you're wanting to use some of these
newer agents and it's worth thinking
about even if you're sticking with
isoflurane
so moving on to alphaxane and propofol
the reason i mentioned this is that
many of you are not going to rush to do
total intravenous anesthesia in rats and
mice those of you who work with larger
species like pigs
like sheep
dog cat
and rabbit
will perhaps be using propofol already
and will have perhaps tried alphaxane
those of you uh in europe may well have
tried alphaxane in its previous
incarnation as a mix of two steroid
anaesthetics alphaxolone and alfadilone
alphaxane is alphaxane alphaxan
formulated with some clever molecular
trickery so that it becomes
water-soluble and it's been relaunched
in europe and it's
i think an australian company
who developed it and started marketing
it
and it's now available in the usa i'm
sorry i'm not sure about canada
so
should i switch from propofol well
there are all sorts of of considerations
in terms of quality of anesthesia the
two drugs are actually very similar
they're both relatively non-cumulative
you can keep giving top-ups without
unduly prolonging recovery times
you can give them both by continuous
infusion they have rather different
pharmacologies
and different solubilizing agents
propofol usually comes in intralipid a
fat emulsion but there is also a
a non-lipid formulation available
so what it comes down to is what do you
need for your particular research
protocol
and what uh how could the pharmacology
of these two different drugs propofols
are hindered phenol alphaxane is a
steroid
anesthetic how could they interact with
your protocol
what particular features do you need for
this anaesthetic
but if i have a long anaesthetic to do
and i don't want to use an inhalant
anaesthetic or it's impracticable to do
that then i would think about
popping an iv line in which is easy in a
rat
trickier in a mouse but something you
can do
and running with one of these agents
so
moving on to the other group of agents i
said i'd mention
dex-meditomadine is the latest alpha-2
agonist that's become available in north
america and also in europe
in europe we also have metatamine
and of course all of us have had
xylazine for decades
it's surprising to me that fewer people
in a research setting have
stuck with uh of switch from xylazine to
um
metatamidine or dexmelatomidine
okay i was just getting a message to say
you might have have lost me but
it seems as though we're okay again
dex meditomidine is simply the dex
isomer
um metatamine is a mixture of 5050 dex
metatamadine and levo meditomidine
the levof form
is
not
almost not active at all
so if you're translating um dose rates
for rodents that are ketamine metatamine
or indeed for
any other species
then
you simply halve the dose in milligrams
or micrograms
so if you're giving 0.1 milligrams of
metatamidine you'd give 0.05 milligrams
of dexmeditomed
they're both more specific alpha 2
agonist and xylazine however in
practical terms you will still see the
same profile of side effects of
vasoconstriction of cardiac depression
and so forth
which is why if you're going to use
these agents you need also to buy the
antagonist and even if i can't persuade
you to move from xylazine to the newer
drugs still by the antagonist
this
reverses virtually all of the
undesirable side effects of
hydroxylazine or metatamidine or
dexmedatomidine
one other thing to add because we're
often using these drugs
together with ketamine which is
acidic and irritant if we give it
intramuscularly
we can cause muscle damage and we can
certainly cause pain
many of us will give the drug ip
and we know that that route of
administration is not the best and is
likely to lead to some failures
wesley burnside working in our lab
compared subcutaneous dosing and found
that
it's easy it's quick
and the onset in mice is just as rapid
as with the other routes
so it's certainly worth worth trying if
you've not used that route in the rat um
i'm more cautious and i like more data
because sometimes it's worked well in
other times we've not been as we've not
been as happy
so
that's a brief run through some of the
drugs that we might think about using
what i want to turn now to now is what
they all have in common
not just those drugs but all the others
that appeared on those graphs and what
they have in common is they all depress
respiratory function so they can cause
hypercapnia and hypoxia and acidosis
they all depress thermoregulation and so
can cause hypothermia
and they all depress the cardiovascular
system to some extent or other
so we're trying to do
carefully controlled
anaesthetics in a reproducible way in
ways that don't influence our animal
models
so
don't those effects matter
and shouldn't we know how cold our
animals become
or how how how hypoxic or hypercatnik or
hypotensive
we've got monitoring devices available
that can help us answer that question
even for small rodents now for the last
a couple of decades at least we've had
electronic devices that we can attach to
larger species
to monitor them
and however enthusiastic i get during
this seminar about these electronic
devices let's not forget that the single
most important thing to have when you're
giving an anesthetic
is clinical monitoring to have a person
watching the animal
but we have to face fact in a high
pressure
environment in a research facility
our anaesthetic assistant is almost
certainly having to help with other
things
and they're only human so they get
distracted
they're asked to perform other tasks
or because they're only human they
actually can't measure the required
parameter so i can't tell you what a
mouse's blood pressure is
or what is carbon dioxide in its expired
gases
or what its body temperature is
so i really need some electronic devices
i should i can't even tell you what a
mouse's heart rate is
because i can't count fast enough
this is a screen grab from our physio
suite attached to a mouse and i think
you can see we had a heart rate of 600
beats a minute
does it matter that it's 600 beats well
what i'd like to know
is if while i'm doing the procedure that
heart rate drops to 500 to 400
to 300
by the time it gets to 200 i'll be able
to count it but i would like to know
where it started and what it how it's
changing and the electronic devices can
help me do that
so
as i said those of you working with
large species there isn't a problem just
say the sky's the limit depends on your
budget but you can get a whole range of
devices that will help you
with
anaesthetic monitoring with small
rodents our choices have been limited
but they're improving greatly
once you get down below guinea pig in
size that's when you start to need to
purchase some of the the specialist
apparatus
so
let's look briefly at pulse oximetry for
those of you who not familiar with it
what is doing is measuring
the percent saturation of the animal's
hemoglobin
which is a reflection of how well its
tissues are going to be oxygenated if
its circulation is good
it also looks at the wobble on the pulse
signal that is that it's looking at and
that gives you pulse rate
it needs to have its probe positioned
over a nice well perfused capillary bed
to work properly so the probe size and
positioning can be an issue
you've got a couple of examples here of
a clip probe
on a mouse
using one instrument
and a little circular probe that slides
over the mouse's foot
on the right here
in the past the
high heart rates and the low signal
strengths were a real problem
but now we have instruments that can
cope with that
and certainly if you want to get pulse
oximetry in mice
this really isn't much of a problem now
and you can look at these different
devices and see how well they suit your
needs
capnography still is a bit of a problem
so this is measuring the carbon dioxide
in expired breath and also an inspired
gas if you want to know that you've been
using your anaesthetic circuits
effectively
these devices either give you a number
which is the concentration of carbon
dioxide at the end of expiration or they
give you a waveform showing you the
pattern of exploration of co2
they fall into two groups either devices
that sit in the airway
and have the sensor right next to the
animal and these are mainstream
devices
or you have devices which have a little
suction proton
which sucks out
gas from the breathing system and
analyzes it in the instrument
both of them have problems with small
animals
the
mainstream devices even with pediatric
attachments introduce a significant dead
space
and the side stream devices
sample at relatively high rates
relatively high for rats and mice for
larger species you can use both equally
well
for the rat you can get
reasonable waveforms with both types of
device with mice our experience is that
even the specialist instruments don't
give you accurate pen titles and it's
because we're we're really
asking an awful lot of them
so i think that technology is not quite
there but pulse oximetry no problems at
all
so
monitoring is great
and it tells you your your mouse perhaps
or your rat is hypoxic
and if it's hypoxic you can perhaps
presume it might also have high carbon
dioxide is hyper chemic
so what you do
well one of the obvious things you can
do
is intubate it
i've got a quick question which i'll
take because we're on pulse oximetry
which is recommendations for pulse
oximetry um in
pigmented animals um in this case
primates but it applies
to um
all species modern pulse oximeters can
cope with that and
we haven't
found a particular issue but what i
always say to people and i'm sorry to
any vendors listening
i suggest that you ask for a trial and
make sure that that instrument with that
particular sensor works in your setting
um because there are quite a lot of
variables in how you use the instrument
and and
how much is being moved and so forth but
modern sensors really should cope with
pigmented skin
so what i was saying is what you do well
the other it's not just
no nice new electronic devices and new
drugs it's relatively simple kit
that will help you do things that in the
past were really quite difficult
and that's one of these is endotracheal
intubation
and
jumping the gun trish you're asking what
do i recommend to incubate a rat with
well the kit here
um i actually buy
we actually have one of these tilting
tables purchased from one vendor
and this fiber optic system purchased
from another
and you can the tilting table is because
i'm getting old and i don't like
crouching down for long periods looking
down
rats when they're placed horizontal on
the table so you lay your rat on the
table on the tilting table and then it
tilts up um to form
that angle
and you can look down
this is being very ambitious you can
look down
from if i get this right
oh it's refusing to do it now
from up here from the top end of that
arrow so you're looking down into the
larynx and getting the view in the
middle um
let's get that right
so you get that view
um which is
looking down this axis
at the animal with the table inclined
you thread your catheter onto the fibre
optic
light source we use an over the needle
catheter
we use for rats anything from
a 16 gauge
down to a 20 gauge depending on the size
of rat and your level of
expertise and start with a slightly
smaller catheter and then move on and
for mice
we're using
22 24
gauge catheters again
look at postmortem as to what will fit
easily and how you can use it there are
other devices i should add and a lot of
this depends on how good you are
juggling dominant and non-dominant hand
to to use these the tilting table is
designed to be used with a
modified otoscope speculum in fact i'll
often use all three the fiber optic to
give me nice illumination and guide my
catheter the tilting table to get the
animal at the right angle
and um
the
speculum to open the mouth another
question just popped up is are there any
endotracheal tubes available with cuffs
on the end
not
that i'm aware of for rodents and
actually i'm not a fan of some of the
very small cuffed tubes that have been
made for the exotic pets market because
the dead space is is large in the tube
and you can't cut it to size what we do
and i'm sorry i haven't put the slide in
is we we slide a small piece of silastic
tubing over the
um
endotracheal tube
about in a rat about half a centimeter
or so back from the tip
and when you tie the tube in place that
silicon tubing pushes up against the
larynx so right in there
and acts as a seal right on the the
larynx and that prevents leaking
if you've got an appropriate ventilator
you can compensate for small leaks in
the system
for some of you those of you who are
thinking i'm just never going to do this
but i would like to give oxygen
and i can't use a face mask because it
gets in the way of my surgery
think about
intranasal catheters
this guinea pig
has a urinary catheter
excuse me slid
into its nereys
this rat has an infant feeding tube
the external nares is the smallest
diameter you can push the tube in in the
rat that's gone in about half a
centimeter
we've lubricated it first and we can
deliver anaesthetic gases and we can
adjust the flows and if we want to use
volatile anesthetics the concentration
to compensate for any breathing up the
other nostril
it's easy it works really well and it's
a great solution
if you don't have a purpose-made mask
for your stereotaxic frame for
delivering oxygen to animals in a
stereotax
finally i want to mention
monitoring body temperature
all of these anaesthetics depress
body temperature regulation we shave our
animals for asepsis we open body
cavities
we blow anaesthetic gases sometimes at
high flows a liter a minute or so
and we also get evaporative losses when
we we open the abdomen and we get
evaporation from the respiratory tract
and then on top of that for those of us
working at the small end of the lab
animal scale um we have very tiny
animals with big surface areas relative
to their body mass
this graph
plots surface area
relative to
body weight between mouse and blue whale
and you can see there's a lovely linear
relationship but this is a log log plot
and the relationship would actually be
curvy linear if i i plotted it linearly
and what it would show you is that the
mouse has a disproportionately high
surface area relative to its body mass
compared to the whale or species in
between
the consequence of this uh we've got
here some data from a wet lab we ran
years ago where we had
five rats on different heating systems
and our homeothermic system
worked well or reasonably well
the other systems worked
not too badly um our blue line our non
homeothermic
heated pad uh didn't do too well
initially and then caught up and that's
because we didn't let it reach 38
degrees before we put the rat on it and
had we done that would have been much
more successful if we didn't nothing
we got down to 28 degrees
now you may say but i'm never going to
run a wrap for four hours or five hours
anesthesia but that was a single dose of
injectable anaesthetic
and we'd slowed metabolism so much that
the animal was not going to recover
so they're going to lose heat and we've
got to keep them warm
and we've got to be sure that the
methods we're using to keep them warm
are working because if we don't we'll
get slow recoveries
we'll get immunosuppression and
increased risk of post-op infection and
if we really have problems we'll get
cardiac arrest if we get very low
temperatures and don't forget
small changes in temperature we're going
to get massive changes in
cell membrane kinetics enzyme pathways
and so forth so let's not rely on on
clinical monitoring let's have a
thermometer that works they're available
from a range of vendors you can get ones
that come together with
a heating system
that's
monitoring the mouse and the pad
and making sure there's no overheating
as well as under heating you can get
stand-alone systems for larger species
there are plenty available but the key
thing to do
is check what the lowest temperature is
because in some thermometers designed
for clinical use the assumption is
you'll never be colder than 35 degrees
and trust me with a small rodent you can
be
there are lots of heating systems i'm
not going to
go into any details but
just to make a plea for anyone who is
keen on
home electronics or any vendors out
there i would love a bear hugger a
forced air warming system that was
scaled down to work with rodents because
they are so effective with larger
species it would just be great if we
could have one for rats and mice
when we're going to wake the animal up
we're going to carry on with this
monitoring until we're sure that all is
well and the animal is
ready to go back to either a recovery
area or to its home cage
and one of the key things that we're
going to do
is ensure good analgesia which brings us
on to the next
phase of this session
which is pain assessment
and where where are we now
i think where we are now is a situation
where there is a huge increase in in
interest in providing analgesia for all
species of animals um
and naturally then working out how to
give the most effectively
this is a quick troll through google
scholar doing a citation analysis on
post-operative pain alleviation animals
and veterinary and what you see is that
nothing much happened
until this decade
and we'll do it again uh in the near
future and i suspect that will have gone
up even further
and what we're seeing is a huge increase
in interest and that being translated
into greater analgesic use
but that increase in analgesic use
is rather slow coming i'll bring this
right up to date at the end of the
session but this is claire richardson
and
emma's data
from these public these publications
um this again is
analysis of the literature
looking at reported analgesic use
although with the um
the richardson and flagler study we also
did an email follow-up to ask about
reporting
and what we found was that analgesic
reporting was very low in the 90s
but had come up to 20
of all publications involving uh surgery
in rats and mice in 2005 to 2006
but that's still a relatively low use as
i say i'll come back to it we'll talk
about why
or some reasons why
so of course looking at that low pattern
of use you can say well
surgery causes pain in people
the neurophysiology is the same let's
give animals the benefit of the doubt
and give them analgesics
and that's what i always used to say
and that was largely supported if you
gave
appropriate doses of analgesics for
relatively short periods
but if you start to give big doses of
drugs like meloxicam and i'm not
singling out metacam any non-steroidal
could do this you can end up
with gi toxicity
but
one or two doses
immediately around the time of surgery
are very rarely going to cause problems
like that
but prolonged usage is difficult which
mean can be can be difficult and can
cause side effects so what we need to
think about is how much and for how long
and that's a difficult question
much of our data on analgesic efficacy
and safety comes from
basic pain research and here's one
example of giving
morphine to all of these different
inbred strains and looking at efficacy
on a hot plate test
and we have strains here where the
effective dose 50 is less than 5
milligrams per kilo
and strains here where it's 20 to 25 mix
per kilo
now the dose needed for controlling
post-surgical pain may be much
less
or maybe different
um
and
we need to know
what dose is appropriate for our strain
of mouse or our strain of rat in our
facility having undergone the particular
surgical procedure
we need to know when we've chosen a drug
and given it if it's worked
when we should repeat the dosing
and when we can stop treating now these
are pretty fundamental questions and yet
we've been dodging them in our research
activities for many many years we've
assumed that you know the best we can do
is give some analgesics and almost hope
for the best
well i think we can move on now because
where we were
was we were using clinical impression or
to be more honest um our intuition
because we work with love animals
whether we're investigators or
veterinarians or vet techs
we just know
well the sad fact is we don't just know
we can pick up i think extremes
of problems related to pain or distress
but how often do we see that most of the
time we're dealing i think with mild to
moderate pain
we took on board
what our colleagues were doing with
medical clinical practice
and
we started using numerical rating
systems and visual analog scoring
then we got colleagues in veterinary
clinical practice coming up with much
more rigorously constructed pain scales
like the glasgow pain scale for use in
dogs and we also looked at some
objective measures
but many of these either required a lab
for example looking at corticosterone
responses or were retrospective
where we are now
is that many of us
have looked at our animals have assessed
their normal behavior
have looked for pay for behaviors that
either increase or decrease in frequency
after surgery
have picked up on abnormal behaviors
and started to select behaviors that we
think we can use for cage side pain
scoring
and for some species and for some
surgeries we've got very good data
to back that up
so back in 2000 uh johnny rowan
developed pain scoring systems for rats
that could be applied after laparotomy
and there are other publications to
support johnny's findings and he's gone
on to publish a whole string of papers
validating that approach
but those behaviors and this is the
illustration from this early paper on
rats with renal calculi
only occur with laparotomy and of course
we want to look at thoracotomies and
jugular cannulations and craniotomies
and so forth
we have similar data in the mouse and
we're gaining data in rabbit and in
guinea pig
and this is some pre-publication data
from yvette ellen
who did a doctor of enemy medicine
thesis with with us
these are guinea pigs a poster
orchidectomy a group who received what
we would consider inadequate analgesia
and a group receiving a local
anaesthetic plus meloxicam and this is
the count of abnormal behaviors uh
observed by video monitoring these
animals
so event will be reporting this in full
but i put it up to show that
even with a species that we think
freezes when you look at it you can come
up with a pain score system but i would
add she did this by using remote video
monitoring
so we can use behaviors but we can also
use another behavior and that's pulling
a face
and for
a long time
nobody really picked up on this until
jeff mogel's lab published in 2010
showing that mice have pain faces
and we know that babies have pain faces
and children have pain faces and the
internet will show us that dogs and cats
have pain faces but what about other
species and can we use it to score pain
well here's some data from again from
one of yvette's studies uh two mice are
both undergone vasectomy both received
analgesics
the mouse on the left just looking at
pain faces i would say
he's doing okay
i still might want to look at him again
and
check that he doesn't need more
analgesics but the one on the right
of my right anyway
is showing orbital tightening
has got some cheek bulging some nose
bulging
and i think needs a top up with either
more carpro fan or a different analgesic
so to answer the question do animals
have pain faces yes they do
can we use them for cage side assessment
yet
we can start but what we have to do is
go into this with our our eyes wide open
we're going to see a string of
publications over the next year or so
dealing with pain faces in macaques in
dogs and cats in horses in pigs and
sheep perhaps even in fish
and in mouse rat rabbit
but what we know in certainly these
species
is that there are numerous other factors
that can affect facial expression
that sedation can be a major confound
and
infuriatingly there are
different expressions of
degree of grimacing in different mouse
strains
so i don't think it's going to prove to
be the gold standard for assessing pain
but i do think it's going to be a really
useful technique i want to illustrate
what i mean about the confounding
factors again
thanks to yvette with some data from her
thesis
these are three strains of mice valve
c's c3he's and c57 black sixes
on the left we've got a group
who've had vasectomy surgeries
on the right
mice who've just had an anaesthetic
and what we can see is that our balb
seas are both pulling what look like
pain faces
our c3hes who've had surgery are pulling
a pain face
but it's not so obvious uh in our c3hgs
have just had an aesthetic and our bowel
seas
are doing pretty much nothing
so what you need to know
just as with pain behaviors
you need to know how your strain of
mouse behaves normally you need to do
the same
with pain faces and look at some control
mice and see what's happening
and hopefully both yvette
and amy miller who's
working in our lab
will publish to explain how you can
approach this problem and how you can
tackle it
finally i want to mention some really
interesting new metrics that again might
be translatable to cage side assessments
and these have come out of a
dissatisfaction from the pain research
community that the standard old measures
of nociceptive testing of hot plate and
tail flick and so forth
weren't proving particularly successful
in developing new drugs particularly for
chronic and neuropathic pain
and
there have been moves in assessing these
types of pain in people to move away
from pain questionnaires and visual
analog scores to developing sort of
quality of life scoring of looking at
how well people function did they get up
were they motivated to get up to go out
to socialize to get dressed to wash to
keep house and so forth
and are the parallels in rodents
and could that be building a nest
socializing with your cage mates
maintaining a burrow and performing
other highly motivated behaviors
and i think the probably the first step
in developing this was the
use of burrowing behavior which was
proposed as a measure of general
uh well-being in rodents
and the initial paper showed that it was
influenced by viral and bacterial
infections and by cns lesions
and then it was demonstrated
in 2011
that rats with peripheral nerve injury
with neuropathic pain
and with inflammatory pain reduced their
digging behavior
and this was digging um
gravel out of a test bowl
and that if you gave analgesics you
could reverse that normalize the digging
and just recently we have another
publication
looking at this in joint pain and i'm
sure more will follow
we also have data in mouse
from pauline jerkoff in switzerland
and sorry i'm trying to pick up a
question and it's disappeared but i'll
pick it up later
um and a quick apology uh that i spelt
her name correctly here but not on the
next slide
she's looked at latency to borrow as
well as
weight of pellets
post surgery and in other circumstances
in mouse and this is some of her data
from this paper
spelt
one f not two if you want to go and
download it
this is latency to borrow in hours
in mice who've either had surgery
surgery plus pain relief
or the appropriate anaesthetic controls
and what you're seeing uh compared to
baseline which is an orange
is that all of these procedures
decrease um the
increase the time taken to borrow
but giving analgesics
to mice have had surgery reduces that
latency significantly
i urge you to read the full paper and
the other publications from this group
which developed this whole idea uh very
clearly and what i would say is that all
you need is a bottle
and some pellets of diet
to try this out
and once again you need to know does my
strain of mouse burrow
how quickly does it burrow and can i use
this as a quick test of its perhaps we
should say its well-being
the group in switzerland have also
looked at nest building as have some
other groups
and once again like other measures
nest buildings affected by other factors
and at the moment what we'd say is that
if we see a mouse that was building a
well-formed nest and it no longer does
that
um
then it needs your attention and it
could be pain or it could be something
else
what do i propose about the personal
resective mice um again i'll come back
to that later i'm trying to pick up
questions as we go um because i know
some of you will dash off to other
sessions
but i'll try and catch up
with all of these shortly
so
nest building if we're providing
nestlets as environmental enrichment
and we're looking at our mice then we
can apply some of those assessments
uh perhaps borrowing is something we can
incorporate as a measure and we need to
know what other factors affect it
how it varies between strains and what's
the best way of doing this assessment
but i'm really optimistic i think we've
already overcome
major misconceptions about the nature of
pain in animals
the responses to pain in animals
what analgesics we can use and the
relative importance of their side
effects
and how about the progress we've made
the real progress in terms of how many
rats and mice and i'm focusing on
rodents because they're the species we
know from these literature reviews are
least likely to get analgesics
how well are we doing with them and this
again is robert's data
which i hope he's going to publish uh
shortly
uh he repeated the 2005 6
literature analysis and added in 2012 to
13 using the same uh
literature review strategy for selecting
the papers
and we've improved over those that time
course but we still only have 22 percent
of those of those publications
specifically saying they gave an
analgesic post surgery
we have another 27
in which the analgesic that was used uh
sorry the anaesthetic that was used had
an analgesic component
but we're getting nearly half those
animals
not receiving
anything
now
why is that well i think one of the key
issues is not that people don't care or
they don't think about the issue
but they are concerned that if they give
an analgesic
it can interact with their research
protocol and confound their research
data
and since the only reason we've
justified using animals for this purpose
um is to get good data
that would indeed be a big problem
but i don't think it's an insurmountable
problem
our policy here at newcastle is always
to give at least one dose of analgesic
to give it preemptively so we have the
analgesic working before the animal
recovers it is possible
to use multimodal analgesic protocols if
we can and particularly if the surgery
allows to incorporate local anaesthetic
regimes
and then to try and use a method of pain
assessment and adjust the analgesic
and when we get to the issue of a
research worker who says i'm concerned
because i've seen that buprenorphine has
immune suppressive effects
so i don't want to use it
you take out the publication you say
yeah it does but look at the dose they
had to give to produce that effect
it's 10 or 20 fold higher than the dose
we're proposing to use for post-surgical
analgesia and if that's still a problem
well how about we use non-steroidals and
if that's still a problem what about
local anesthetics and i think there is
always a potential solution we shouldn't
have animals
not receiving anything
so i'm happy to take some questions i
want to close by thanking
the various people who funded
the individuals working at newcastle on
these
issues are part of our pain and animal
welfare science group
i also want to thank particularly
those bodies who have supported our
education activities and to highlight
the national center for the three r's
who've just funded um production of some
interactive learning resources and with
a bit of luck we'll get the url popped
up for you the first one has just been
launched which is introductory
anaesthesia it's free to use via the
nc3rs website and assist at a
second website that we run will allow
tracking of individual users and we
would love to have your feedback on it
to see how it's working and we're hard
at work on the next stage of anaesthesia
more complex anaesthetic procedures and
analgesia and pain assessment and so
forth and we hope over the next year or
so to make those available to you so
thank you very much for listening
and i'm happy to to take some questions
a second website that we will
thank you paul for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session i would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the q a box
which can be found clicking on the green
q a button at the lower left of the
presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can
our first question our lab conducts
mechanical ventilations on laboratory
rats to make sure they are adequately
ventilated we use a blood gas analyzer
do you believe that pulse oximeter
technology has progressed for use in the
rat to the point where it would be
almost as accurate as our current method
um
if you're ventilating your rats with um
room air
then
you will get a reasonable estimate of
how well you're ventilating
but
it won't be as accurate as blood gases
if you're ventilating with
inspired oxygens of
30 40 percent or more which is what
would be normal practice
then you won't get any indication
because the
unless you have terrible ventilation the
pulse oximeter is going to
give you high saturations
if your endotracheal tube's gone down
one bronchus and you're only ventilating
one lung then the pulse oximeter will
pick that up but what you really need is
an alternative to blood gases uh is
capnography
and
one approach that we've used
successfully in the rat
because the the difficulty with
even the newer blood gas
analyzers is the sample volume is
relatively high at least for frequent
sampling
we use um a cathode
uh we measure the entitled carbon
dioxide and we take a blood gas and we
adjust our ventilation if necessary take
another one
um and we can then follow the trend on
our catnograph and if that stays stable
that has proved to be a good reflection
of what's happening to
arterial pco2
and that avoids the need to take
multiple blood gases right the way
through and then at the very end you can
take a last one to reassure yourself
that all worked well
so i'm afraid pulse oximetry
no uh
there is a capnograph that's marketed
for rodents that will give you a really
nice accurate waveform
but it is very very temperamental in our
hands and we've tried three versions of
the of the instrument email me offline
and i'll give you more details but um i
think the approach that you've got a
blood gas analysis
maybe incorporating a capnograph would
uh
would help
now i just need to remember to pass back
to brenda
who can get the whoops who can get the
sorry brain drive i press the wrong
button
and i seem to have
really messed up here
no worries paul here i am
uh we have another question regarding
pain scoring why not evaluate muscle
contraction or body movements
so the question is to
evaluate muscle contractions and body
movements so during anaesthesia of
course we use these reflex responses um
routinely
when we're doing our clinical
observations of animals we look at body
posture and we'll look at
activity and certainly if for example
you've got a painful limb then the
animal's favoring it and it's pretty
obvious that there is an issue there
differentiate differentiating between
mechanical impairment of a limb and
pain causing reluctance to use a limb
can be difficult
and rather disappointingly
work from ourselves and others looking
at
overall activity levels
have not been particularly successful
when you do more sophisticated analyses
for example looking at circadian rhythms
that's much more helpful but i suspect
that many of those analyses are actually
looking at
more than just pain
and
i say that because often
analgesics do not normalize those
changes rapidly
and yet to all intents and purposes the
animals appear pain-free
so my hopes at the moment are
a combination of some
altered highly motivated behaviors some
abnormal behaviors and pain faces as a
way of coming up with some composite
scoring not neglecting simple things
like weighing the animal and looking at
its food and water consumption
thank you paul just as an aside so the
audience knows pdf of
dr flucknell's slides will be available
in the resource center here immediately
after the session is over you can leave
the presentation log back in and they'll
be available
our next question is
what kind of bedding material would you
recommend for housing lab animals after
surgery
so we use a product um
that was originally called vet bed um
it's also called dry bed
it's a synthetic sheepskin a synthetic
fleece i think would be my north
american translation
it's autoclavable machine washable
urine drops through it it's great for
big animals and it's great for small
animals
rats and mice will chew it but they take
a long time to destroy it and we haven't
had problems with
large numbers of fibers being ingested
and we use that a lot any of you who
have picked up on on
images that we've produced we often have
an animal sitting on on dry bed
there are alternatives but what what i
would say to avoid are sawdust and any
material that's going to stick to the
animal's
nose mouth
anus
because that's going to
make you feel uncomfortable it's going
to need to be groomed off um and of
course if it gets rubbed into its eyes
that can be a real problem so i prefer
that tissues i find pretty unsuccessful
because the animal the first thing it
seems to do is push them out of the way
i'm sure maybe someone else has got some
some other materials that they really
like but it needs to be absorbent it
needs to be non-irritant and it needs to
avoid going into the animals eyes and
mouth
thank you paul we have another question
is anybody working on biochemical
markers of pain and animals so that a
simple blood test can be developed for
pain assessment other than steroids
i'm sure there's a great deal of
activity in the pain research community
to look for biomarkers of pain and there
are
molecular markers of particular types of
pain that are being developed but what
we're interested in i think is is
something we can use
if not cage side but quickly and easily
what you might be able to to uh to do is
say okay i'm doing the same surgery the
same strain of animal for the next year
same surgeon
let's
assess the first few animals using our
hypothetical biomarker show that our
analgesic regime's working and away we
go
the problem with that is that we know
from experiencing people that the
efficacy of analgesics and the degree of
pain
varies tremendously from person to
person uh
and even if they've undergone the same
surgery with the same surgeon
and there's a concept in
analgesic clinical trials called a
number needed to treat which is the
number of patients you need to give your
drug to to get a 50 reduction in their
pain
and the number you need to give for
example oral tramadol to ranges from
four to six depending on the clinical
trial so what that means is that when we
give our standard drug
to our standard mouse after its standard
surgery
there is the likelihood that some of
those mice will need some additional
analgesics and the only way we are going
to be able to do that in a way that will
benefit those particular mice
is by assessing their pain cage side and
intervening and giving more drug so
that's why i'm keen on these these
real-time pain assessments
and i do appreciate the logistics
of that and the difficulties that can
that can produce
in a research busy research environment
thanks paul
our next question do you still encourage
oral administration with
buprophenorphene
we have a model of hemophilia in rodents
and tried morphing sr to limit
injections but the resulting hematoma
can induce more bleeding
we'd like to try one injection of that
and then p.o buprenorphine but are
getting pushed back what is your answer
what is your opinion
so the
um
giving buprenorphine orally there are
now three or four
five or six publications describing
different approaches to doing that in
drinking water in drinking water plus
supplement
in
materials like nutella and so forth
one of the problems uh is that
sometimes it's not going to work and
there are some publications from the u.s
showing that even at high doses
quite clearly in some rats you don't get
good analgesic efficacy one of my
pharmacology colleagues
suggests that this is because the
first past extraction of
rather the low bioavailability of
buprenorphine when you give it by mouth
which is
something like 90 percent to 95 percent
uh simply is is is not available um uh
to have activities and analgesic
small changes in um that fraction that's
available can have big effects on the
analgesic effect
so we've we've used it ourselves
it has attractions as with other oral
formulations of being able to give the
drug
and
then leave the animal alone uh it can it
can dose itself if you've dropped the uh
food pellet in it's habituated to that
but you need to combine that with pain
assessment and so for that reason i
preferred giving inject
thank you paul
we have another question do you have any
experience or advice using long-acting
topical fentanyl in laboratory animals
but it's worth looking at and the final
thing i'd say is assess whether you
really need um opioid level um
of pain control
after that subsequent injection uh and
is there something else you could use
although i suspect um if you're looking
at a model you're using you don't want
non-steroidals that even temporals that
even
thank you i think we're having a
technical issue
we'll have one more question
what is your thought on combining
anesthetics in rodents i.e low-dose ket
saline
subcutaneous with isoflurane
i think that's a really excellent idea
and it's a really good approach
one i'm surprised someone didn't pop up
and say we've tried ketamine metatamine
in mice it doesn't work
and there are again there are
publications out there showing that in
some strains of mice
you don't get
full planes of surgical anesthesia now
when you've given your cocktail of drugs
either intraperitoneally or
subcutaneously
giving a top-up dose can be a little bit
hit-and-miss
and one of the simplest things you can
do is give a very low concentration
that's all you'll need on isofluorine
so something like half a percent
isofluorine
to supplement your injectable
is going to give you that deepening of
anesthesia
that you might not otherwise get you can
also say well i do get full surgical
planes of anesthesia
with ketamine meditomidine but i also
get undesirable side effects
let's drop the dose i'm using down to
reduce those side effects and supplement
with an inhalant
and you can also
add yet another component and say and
i'll use local anaesthetic on my
surgical site
to reduce the degree of surgical noxious
stimulation
and keep my my other anaesthetic doses
even lower
so you've got all of those options and
just as we talked about balanced
analgesia we can talk about balanced
anesthesia and using several different
drugs to achieve the desired effect
and you know
you're the only limits your imagination
you can use all of those combinations
and approaches actions and approaches
thank you very much paul we are out of
time i'd like to thank the audience for
their participation and thank you dr
fleck now for your informative
presentation
and just so everybody knows
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through august
2015. you'll receive an email from lab
roots telling you about this and feel
free to pass that email on
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live broadcast
thank you again and see you next time